the nfl draft is almost here kicks off
two weeks from today and it runs through
the 30th the friday of that week right
now a lot of prep work going on behind
the scenes joe moeller joining us live
now outside the bellagio to walk us
through how it's all going to happen hi
joe
hi there good evening to both of you we
have excitement is happening excitement
is here the countdown is on the nfl
draft is now less than two weeks away
i'll give you a look at some of the prep
so we have a couple lanes closed here at
the on the strip for the preparations
they've been taking some equipment off
the trucks throughout the day and the
big part of this the red carpet take a
look at the bellagio fountains this
evening they are getting ready to put
the red carpet right here right in front
of the iconic bellagio
i thought it would be like a show or a
concert the nfl draft is taking form
taking a walk down the strip outside the
bellagio is starting to look a lot
different the red carpet is being put
together on the water lane closures are
in place and crews are setting it all up
this will be the one of a kind red
carpet where nfl prospects will walk
through before going to the draft
theater fans will be able to watch it
all from the strip the red carpet stage
will also play host to a number of local
acts during the three-day event visitors
walking the strip were curious wondering
what's going on in the lake
why they're setting up a stage
now back out here live a lot of people
walking by wondering what exactly is
going on we've been answering a number
of questions for folks out here but
setup is underway the red carpet will be
right here in just less than two weeks
but there's another big part of the
entire draft the draft experience which
is just around the corner from here
we'll have much more on that coming up
at 6 30 that is reporting live on the
strip john muller live local now